[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we need a
triangle or some three years and
accumulator than that thing should be
the next thing we do that's the next
instrument that's good
present idea or we should get them like
a really big organ if the children's a
core never assumed hold it it's at Alice
mall he does really my god the classes I
think everybody knows about plays like
that am I out of my mind it's a piano on
one side and it's [ __ ] random like
Braille buttons on the other side I see
wow it's really hard like we're doing
this to all you're doing it yeah but
that seems like that seems like the
funny part is yeah I'm so excited for
things giving dude oh yeah my favorite
time of the year right now we're doing
it at boo yeah hell yeah
this time man Christmas time I'm talking
about that we love seasons we [ __ ]
love it and we're talking about going to
get a get a get a cabin [ __ ] catch us
up we weren't in that result we're doing
our really really fun guy only writers
mean like we always did at least twice a
week
oh that's a great time for the girls cuz
we get our free time are you saying it
that way because you're trying to like
get a reaction out of us I do we really
miss you know oh we're trying to help
promote males in the creative and the
movie industry so we're still
underrepresented thank you so Evan what
do you think
so pretty much Joe was like hey what do
you guys think if I got a cabin out in
Big Bear around Christmastime and then
we just hang out there there's snow
because we're not really do anything out
here it doesn't even feel like Christmas
and like [ __ ] yeah let's do it
so I'm pretty down if you're down and
steez down or whatever but y'all maybe
chipped in and get one giant elf cabin
have fun we're gonna be we don't know
you don't know where he's equipment we
didn't say you didn't say Christmas Day
he said Christmas time yeah okay cuz
we're here the first week of army that's
a girl trip time
oh so we are going on the girl chat
about doing a girl tradition tell you
know we have a chat with all the girls
where we meet more than twice alo space
the whole space I do that stop my thing
I should do it why I think you guys are
not enough what do you think we should
do it just cuz I feel like girls like
you guys don't um I don't I think for
dudes whenever I like a dude wants to do
something we pretty much just end up
taking three steps for me just do it
yeah we have initiative for girls like
you like a lot of you guys want to do
something and I just hear after four
years of talking about it
no yeah what are you talking about we
worked out by the way yeah and you guys
been said hey we should sell oh yeah
because it sounds like me and David I
should probably do a more tie it next
week we're taking more high classes
right it's like literally immediately so
did we being Justin what is it yoga
classes for like consider you know how
even more down it is this well hits me
up in the morning hey you want to go on
a walk alright wake up I wipe the
boogers on my eyes I go to walk no you
don't what the [ __ ] that's the biggest
thing you've ever said you're the
biggest [ __ ] flaker all that's on
weight you were an hour late today
what is that walking yeah I don't know
you know but that is what you say
because
you know under said cuz I he said
there's no planning I I thought you're
gonna say you're the cleanest eyes ever
you'll get boogers yeah because we're
saying that there's no planning because
we're just gonna do and we just do if we
snare an idea which is nice
that's where guys [ __ ] up okay all seven
of our chicks in the same room you know
maybe they like building IKEA furniture
or something with the ball and a [ __ ]
carnies throw it off the bridge all I'm
saying is that I'm really proud of you
guys because you guys want to do
something you guys are doing it and I'm
really happy you guys never do it it's
not taking over twelve months for it to
happen so I'm like that's by the way
that's not a bit he's saying that very
earnest anyway so what are we doing for
Thanksgiving oh yeah I offered our place
because it seems to be the one that
could fit people
well it's everybody not going away for
Thanksgiving it's just not we never go I
usually draw it all away you go we're
here we're from here we go we're from
here family hit would you like but don't
you guys hang out Thanksgiving with your
buddies family your family never yes
okay I go to my Asian side in Long Beach
and then I go to San Diego for my I do
both here in the same day only so we're
not gonna build we're not gonna do the
dance Diego well maybe I'll try to get
out of it not because it doesn't thing
cuz it's a well Nikki says that you guys
don't do it on the day day yeah that's
true defense that's very true
sorry you know are you getting a whole
saying your house you know I mean we're
down we're down to what's it but you
guys bring the food are you guys down or
do you want do you know we're down we
are down you don't want it so you don't
wanted it we got it on video
what the [ __ ] do you want from me but
yeah we clear okay so for me when people
say they're down it's just up in the air
like if I'm options she gave you the ice
you're talking less other - that's why
ignore her you want the whole set no
doubt it's like if it happened woke up
in English yeah but Bart's hearing a
woman talk so he's like well guys get
[ __ ] done but is she really gonna get
[ __ ] done why not yeah Oh what are you
saying
oh really so women don't get [ __ ] done
is that what we're saying we don't have
a female president right what sounds
more damn [ __ ] worthy okay hey I'm down
a [ __ ] I want to [ __ ] you so she said
I'm down the hall Thanksgiving or I want
to hold thanks you guys don't come up I
see for me down it's even more than I
want know for me down - down for me down
just means now I'm open to doing it if
someone else is doing it but if you say
what they're doing it's fun no but if
you want to do it that means you're
doing the no matter how you saying cuz
you did say it emphatically so if you're
like I'm down yeah different his hookin
big-block head is intimidating to 10 so
she's just like oh my god am I gonna do
even Jim in look how nice you look until
he snapped your arm off yeah he's a pet
he's a teddy bear yep yeah okay Steve
knows come on now this room is a [ __ ]
sausage fest I get to host Thanksgiving
but she does not want to be in my house
so at the condo so you guys just come
but your [ __ ] tiny D that's what I
was saying like bring your food over
absolutely not I'm not cooking [ __ ]
30 pounds of food and transferring it
already
all right cook 30 pounds of food at our
place we'll have a nice kid what do you
cook David well I'm going to do your mom
your mom could go to our house - she
saying yeah I know but I don't know if
my mom wants to know so that's ask her
so I'm doing turkey obviously we're
gonna do the cranberry sauce creme at
David's house right we're gonna do the
slow cooker ham just because I don't
want to use up the oven space for it so
like I like doing in a slow cooker so
you could just it's like pulled pork
almost and then I just do like the honey
glaze at the top of it
David's mouth is salivating like a
[ __ ] yeah - I'm gonna do a mac
and cheese but I'm gonna do it with
white cheddar and the smoked gouda
yeah you've already tasted it the first
ones really bomb I saw your story yeah
but one less way you're prepping for
things give you like that yeah I like I
like weeks and ahead wow that's
interesting it's good best girls we'd
like to get [ __ ] done have you tried
this cooking no yeah you made something
for the Oscars there's this whole period
where I didn't cook for a while so I'm
just like the first time I'm cooking
this amazing I'm thinking about doing a
pinko crust on it but when put butter
with them what is that oh just like
Japanese breadcrumbs and we're gonna
toast it with butter and then we're
gonna do like blue crab on top of it so
it's gonna be a crab mac and cheese and
then I'm thinking about for the size
really just do regular sausage stuffing
and then I might do for appetizers to
like start crude or shades to like chop
it up it's like a little bit of yeah
exactly exactly
he's like - take it easy we'll do
Chilean sea bass you know for the
appetite I'm guessing depending on how
many people come we'll do shrimp
cocktail and then for the veggie I'm
gonna do like a roasted veggie like
salad so it's gonna be it's gonna be not
fresh vegetables will be roasted evil
anyone else will bring anything else
yeah I mean honestly it'd be great if
you guys could just in case I'll bring a
red barons pizza or drinks dessert and
drinks I'll just bring food for like
visit always we go to someone's house or
whatever and then you're just kind of
sitting there like Owens foods gonna be
ready so I'll bring the snacks need to
pull the snack easier well that's why I
had
charcuterie stuff so that's gonna be the
appetizer that [ __ ] is not anything dude
we talked about it oh yeah the tooth
salami and cheese dried meats crackers
spread pate that's not who didn't even
drink you can switch it over your place
let me ask ya way bigger yeah yes I
would love to us at our place but I
please ably small parking period yeah I
can't believe you that you feel like you
plays a small but then I understand what
you mean because you have so many kids
things we got like a big playpen thing
we don't have a house we have a kid yeah
yeah yeah it's perfect if I five people
come over sure but if it's like 20
people and I know your place does have a
huge debt area yeah the whole like
kitchen thing your kitchens way bigger
than my two so I would host what it
feels mean because I live something far
away from you guys there's like everyone
has to come you guys need your own valet
service I know it is weird yeah it's
crazy it's two parking pretty garbage in
here so are you having Thanksgiving here
or back a backward well it depends on
when the family does the [ __ ] cuz I
never know I never know exactly went
into like the week before Thursday yes
Thursday Oh duh that's a sheriff you're
right
I can't believe it's November already I
know dude I was [ __ ] fuzzy months it's
almost Black Friday baby this is the
first time so I've had the same New
Year's goal for the past like 15 years
as the first time I actually completed
this one goal which was the weight loss
thing
like all the way through and I did it a
lot faster than I expected
[ __ ] yeah man that's all on your face
old David yeah what's your next one
minute he's gonna do a profile this was
the US abso-fucking-lutely not I don't I
don't think I have goals no I'm just
giving I think the next goal is just I
want to sell something aside from just a
movie like I want to do like a TV show
or something else I don't know how long
that's gonna take
but you know who knows that was tight
like half Lex and also like I want a
Ferrari you know one of those yeah you
know even though that movie didn't make
me [ __ ] is this Joel on Netflix yeah I
actually just watched it again recently
and I loved it yeah man like it was like
one of those things is like actually
made me tear up the the scene that I
wasn't a part of because I didn't see it
yeah so I if there's no [ __ ] that she's
so good it was a part when a Camilla and
her brother were fighting all watching
the thinning - I wept that's right
no I was I got really emotional this is
a really beautiful movie just get ready
it's a tearjerker some might say that
YouTube read the first one don't have
you to read well you can get a free
30-day trial
you just find one Vimeo me and have them
rip it or something you just said free
30-day trial yeah but that requires
information dude I think I'll hit up how
would you feel if a bunch of people grew
up and knew a lot of people did how did
you feel about it how'd you feel I
didn't make any money so I didn't matter
what do you didn't make money because
they were ripping it yeah if you rip the
black and white films
oh that for Jacob party that's what we
said that day you dare you think no
nowhere
afterwards all of us are we could have
said Guk we're playing this game where
you have the name black one movie and we
can sign never a bit never said good
until afterwards Allah Allah
alright because it felt like it was
colored it's a wonderful life a
Christmas classic I don't know any black
and white movies really I said uh I said
Raging Bull now you did that's not like
it's still probably pretty good up today
I love it
you spoiled that JK party see you
brought about so much disappeared in my
bed it was like two days later oh yes I
just really I can't wait for Black
Friday every [ __ ] year I go out for
Black Friday
nothing I like to watch the people it's
so fun drag Nikki Nikki can't wait to go
Nick are you kidding me Nikki basically
well I drag her and she drags me will
you be both you guys buy anything not
really
maybe I'll get like a shirt please go
early like early early or do you just
like show up later when like people like
well in back in the dizzay dude I used
to Black Friday though is clothing yeah
yeah exams on Black Friday are the
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
that's not biggest sale of the year for
barber ghetto Black Friday final game
that's we're gonna find [ __ ] like over
50% off sometimes I buy my own stuff
dude I'll get my hands on the prestige
good edition
that's just very flattering on your
shape oh thank you that's how a lot of
things are all for 50% off so which I
get up Black Friday bottle brigade yeah
Black Friday for clothing is like this
[ __ ] right now I did I [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] dude I need to clothing line now
cuz all you always got clothing lines
oh my god can you please I might yeah Oh
what I named it the vallini connection
yeah I don't know yeah I'm kicking
around some of them some different
thoughts that I hope you like this
having a clothing brand is the most
stressful thing I've ever more than
dress it's more stressful trip is a
different situation like hey you know
like clothing is more like you have to
be really knowledgeable about well yeah
[ __ ] that and it's very [ __ ]
stressful he evolved so quickly oh maybe
I'm out of my mind this
what this is one big thing that I didn't
really account for coming from a digital
business so in digital business it's
like all these products that we make
there's no real overhead besides the
labor that goes into it so whatever
money you can make from it that's pretty
much profit exactly
but with clothing whatever money that
you make from it half of it you have to
put aside so you could buy more goods to
sell again so you can't just reap
profits all the time so you almost have
to have like four hundred percent
margins to make double the money twice
we just [ __ ] lose best part no that's
part of it the other one is following
trailer getting the four hundred percent
like be even able to stretch the cost of
the pricing it's [ __ ] and timing
everything out accordingly cuz now you
have to ship off your your brain babies
off to the manufacturers and then they
got the source of materials and [ __ ] and
that's a whole [ __ ] timeline so it
takes like a month to lace the brain
babies like hard though okay I knew
nothing about this entire so the things
in your controller the easiest oh we got
this super dope line right and then you
go hey we gotta make this super dev line
and they send them on your dope line
stuff and they go oh so sorry we don't
have black fabric this season it's all
sold out and they're like son of a [ __ ]
and you got to bring it all back there's
a lot of things outside of your control
that goes but it's all [ __ ] up yeah or
you you get a thousand shirts for some
reason this sleeve is like this tight
and this one's down here you're like
what the hell [ __ ] Johnny was smoking
crack while he was making her shirts
Wow they give that specific go by the
way we want you to still pay half for it
you ruin all my [ __ ] now I got a paper
that's what it does so the stuff out of
your control is the and then what sucks
even harder is when you put so much
money time into it and then nobody likes
you get done anything specifically cuz
we only got like four things
yeah we're not my [ __ ] yeah it's just a
really hard businessman like it's
something that I like doing but it's
like at the other time too psyched it I
don't know if I could keep you inside
but it's it's fun though like I think
it's really cool when people wear it and
they were really proud of it too because
like you're proud of the product and
they were and they kind of like
represent what you have so scoffs well
unlike the kid conversation this makes
me want to do a clothing line even more
really just yeah just because I just
think it's so funny that I would have a
clothing line
yeah that alone is what makes me go like
oh that's worth it cuz it sounds so dumb
that I would have a woman and you've
seen my art I'll be one of your design I
already know what your first shirt
should be what should it be
your face like oh probably my face yeah
that's pretty good or just my hair maybe
like an elegant outline everything like
an outline of my hair like a silhouette
yeah could be really so it'd be like a
merged line not really like a entire
clothing well no it would be it would be
a clothes should be once it couldn't so
I want it to be yeah I want to see how
to see yeah like what what you come up
with because I've seen like the truth
you were on a daily basis of lashes
brand of like trolli shirts I'm like I'd
like to see what he would create like
just original right do you game Ryan I
feel like you game oh you're in there
now though do you play the cowboy game
the new cowboy game dude Red Dead
Redemption is sick yeah alright I was
playing at Brandon's house it's [ __ ]
cool it's [ __ ] sick G cool it's like
Grand Theft Auto with puppy horses what
yeah it's like Grand Theft Auto force
hell yeah dude it's tight do you just go
over in a random town jeshu random BL
III rape and pillage the whole
countryside yeah so I did too III go
you're keeping it old school I laughs oh
well here's the thing yeah a little bit
yeah that's a good way look at so I
dressed my character up like Woody from
Toy Story basically yeah it's pretty
close he's pretty close right I saw a
guy do it on reddit and I was like
that's [ __ ] hilarious oh it wasn't
even original no III that it's not an
original give full credit the guy in red
I gave that so but yes why I just my
character like Woody from Toy Story and
then I ride into town and then if
anybody says [ __ ] to me I immediately
well either I blame them or I lasso them
and then take them to train tracks and
learn get run
okay so then how far you in the game now
because it sounds like you get very
distracted III really haven't done much
story yeah games with him no I'm never
would you use a [ __ ] [ __ ] due to
we're playing this racing game out in
virtual reality one yeah we were really
seriously trying to win because we're
all really competitive people and that
like I don't know where you just see
this [ __ ] car just come and go going
the wrong way and so so I see one car
get like swiped off right and then I'm
like still going and then someone just
[ __ ] hits me and I'm like who the
[ __ ] would do that the virtual reality
car it's like a legit race oh you got
like cars someone hits you like it
virtual reality like stay like oh god it
has no power steering if you get if you
start spinning goals like and you have
the Flex [ __ ] hard to bring it back
dude I couldn't [ __ ] breathe I was
laughing sorry I was like crying but my
headset thing was slipping off my face
was I was like crying man you can hear
everyone Vulcan Steve [ __ ] Steve and
then Joe's like you're like very like
actually trying to race around me and
[ __ ] like being very the studious about
it was hilarious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]